-Guys, it is time
for that beloved tradition.
-"Is there a 'Stache
Under That Mask?"
-Here we go.
That's right.
♪♪
This is a game where we --
This is a game where
we pick a random audience member
and guess if there's a 'stache
under their mask.
So, please welcome
tonight's audience member,
Michael Christian.
Michael, where are you sitting?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright.
Michael, come on down.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome, buddy.
Please have a seat.
How are you?
-Hi.
-Nice to see you.
-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to the game "Is There
a 'Stache Under That Mask?"
Michael, where you from?
-I'm from Orlando, Florida.
-Orlando, Florida.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, very good.
That's all --
That's all I can ask you.
-[ Laughs ]
-That's all I can ask you.
Alright,
now we have to figure out
if you've got a 'stache
under that mask.
Quest,
since you're the furthest away,
what do you think?
You can ask him one question
if you want,
and then you must make
your guess.
-Alright.
-Or, if you think you know,
you don't have to ask
a question.
-I'm going to ask a question.
-Okay.
-At Starbucks...
would you order hot chocolate
with or without whipped cream?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
[ Audience ohs ]
-I don't go to Starbucks,
but if I ordered
a hot chocolate,
I would get it
with whipped cream.
-Oh.
-What's your guess?
-I think he's trying
to throw me off.
I think he has a 'stache.
-[ Laughs ] That's ridiculous.
You asked -- Alright.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
Trying to throw you off.
-I don't trust anything now.
-Yeah, Higgins --
Higgins, your turn.
What is -- What is your guess,
or do you have a question?
-I have one question.
-Alright.
You can ask one question.
-Do you have a mustache?
-No, Higgins, you -- No.
[ Rim shot ]
It's got to be -- You can't ask
the -- an obvious question.
-Okay. Alright.
-A different question.
-How about this?
-Yeah, you can't ask that.
-Would people consider you
a scratchy kisser?
[ Laughter ]
-Um.
Man, I'd have to ask my wife,
but I'm going to go with no.
I'm going to say
I'm a great kisser.
-Oh.
[ Audience ohs ]
Great kisser.
-I'm close. It's my turn.
[ Laughter ]
-You want me to lean in?
-I'm close --
-You want -- Okay.
-No, you're leaning in enough.
[ Laughter ]
You look very clean shaven,
I will say, very clean.
-Okay.
-You got a nice fade.
It feels like
you're very groomed almost.
-Okay.
-Hm.
-I'm going to say there's
no 'stache under that mask.
-Gonna say no?
I'm going to say yes 'stache.
-Oh, wait, who said --
What's the answers again?
You said 'stache?
-I'm saying 'stache.
Quest says 'stache.
-I say 'stache.
-I say no 'stache.
Michael...
[ Drum roll ]
-Is there a 'stache
under that mask?
-Please reveal.
[ Drum roll continues ]
-Oh, man! [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Damn it! [ Laughs ]
Oh, man!
Really good job, buddy.
Ah.
This has been "Is There
a 'Stache Under That Mask?"